i hope this is going to work
she wants to focus on the future
butler's truss's past pronouncements
have left some in scotland with a sour
taste
do you think your comments about nicola
sturgeon being an attention seeker have
alienated voters and if if you do win
this leadership race
will you be able to ignore her
well i'm absolutely passionate about
scotland and the united kingdom i grew
up in paisley
i've spent my primary school years there
and what i want is to deliver for the
people of scotland and that's what i'm
focused on is ignoring nicola sturgeon a
sensible strategy no i don't want to
ignore nicolas sturgeon i want to take
her on and beat her and i think we can
make a very strong case for what the uk
government does to help people in
scotland
the first minister will soon face her
fourth prime minister relations with the
third were strained at best
nicola sturgeon believes her country is
on a journey to independence she wants a
second referendum next year
but for some that feels distant compared
to the current energy crisis many here
feeling the pinch seem unconvinced truss
or sunak are well equipped to help rishi
sunak who is partially responsible for
the cost of living crisis and then
maggie thatcher wannabe
couldn't care less who wins out the two
of them they're both terrible for others
anyone's got to be better than the last
boris was absolutely the pits i'm sorry
no i wanted him out
so one of these two will be an
improvement then maybe maybe a slight
improvement on the name
but not on the policies i don't think
nicola sturgeon is never going to be
close friends with the prime minister
but if it is liz trust who enters number
10 relations between westminster and
edinburgh could be fiery and whilst
trading barbs is pretty popular with
party members on each side some senior
conservatives here worry that sort of
behavior feeds a narrative which damages
the union
for the tory's scottish leader who
phoned up boris johnson to tell him to
resign industrial language was used
during the conversation from him or from
it from him the priority is keeping the
party and country united while we
continue to face major challenges
individually and you know collectively
here in scotland the last thing people
want to see is more distraction more
resources being put into campaigning to
divide scotland all over again the
people united will never be defeated as
independent supporters protested at the
front of the hustings
the candidates arrived out back
whoever wins this race westminster is
unlikely to change its approach to the
union but that doesn't mean the next
prime minister won't damage it joe pike
sky news perth